I clearly broke some of your brains with
my relativity series you had a lot of
really good comments and questions let's
see what you had to say
why doesn't light always have to travel
the same speed the speed of any wave is
only dependent on the properties of the
stuff that's waving for something like
water waves or sound that could be
things like material elasticity and mass
density both of which ultimately depend
on things like temperature very easy to
change light is a wave in the electric
and magnetic fields in other words not
matter there's no way to change the
properties of those fields so there's no
way to change the speed of light no
exceptions
which reminds me of something I think
some scientists need to learn if your
rule has exceptions it's not that great
of a rule why you see the symbol we use
for the speed of light because the speed
of light is constant scientists aren't
usually good at naming or labeling
things is there some kind of absolute
universal reference frame no although
they tried really hard to make this a
thing back in the day luminiferous ether
but it was totally bogus
too many assumptions had to be made and
we all know where that leads Brian
Greene said we always move through
space-time at the speed of light and
it's only the direction that we can
change well yes
I even said something like this in a
previous video but you have to be really
careful about the definitions of words
as you can see the word object has many
meanings as long as you limit the word
object to things with mass then you're
fine
light itself doesn't fall under Brian
Greene's statement but light doesn't
have mass either so it's not an object
if you want to know more and have a
solid math background my book covers
this otherwise you can wait for my next
video in the spacetime diagram how come
the second time axis is diagonal or
curved if something is stationary then
it's moving through time and not through
space in a spacetime diagram that's when
your time axis lines up with your path
it has to by definition that's what it
means to be stationary if we were on the
opposite side of the earth would that
mean we were upside down technically
gravity defines down so as long as that
always points towards your feet then
your right side up
what's a geodesic a geodesic is the new
name for an inertial reference frame
let's start all the way back with Newton
his first law defines what an inertial
frame is which is why it's sometimes
called the inertial law it says the
acceleration is zero in inertial
reference frames about 230 years later
Einstein
actually you know acceleration is equal
to this we call it the geodesic equation
and it's like a new and improved version
of Newton's first law so when we
accelerate only time is being curved no
whether you're talking about
acceleration or gravity both space and
time are curved I left off the new space
axis in the diagram for clarity but time
does tend to be more curved than space
so time curvature is where most gravity
comes from if you're floating in the
middle of empty space you just sit in
one place and only move through time
you're geodesics straight in space-time
is flat but if we put the earth in there
your geodesic bends toward the Earth's
surface so that's where you go it takes
something a lot bigger than the earth to
notice curvature in space like a really
big galaxy or a whole cluster of
galaxies or you know a black hole or
something okay if I drop two coins and
opposite sides of the earth and they
each think the earth is accelerating
then the earth has to be accelerating
toward both of them at the same time
first of all each coin is in a different
reference frame so you can only be
looking from the point of view of one at
a time the earth doesn't accelerate
toward both it accelerates toward each
here's the first coins frame the second
coins frame and the earths frame the
distinction is very important because
curvature is only defined locally how
our inertial mass and gravitational mass
the same it seems like they're
completely independent they were seen as
independent for a very long time in fact
Newton had no idea why they were always
the same it took general relativity in
1915 to finally understand the
equivalence principle says acceleration
and gravity are the same thing so these
two equations are basically saying the
same thing so the source of gravity
isn't mass nope
its energy well technically it's energy
and momentum and pressure and stress all
summarized in a quantity called the
stress energy tensor meaning anything
with energy and momentum can curve
space-time and create gravity including
light light might not have any mass but
it has energy and momentum it's all
kinetic energy but it's still energy it
still has the ability to do stuff how
can gravity be considered a fundamental
force if it isn't even a force and how
does the graviton fit into all of this
this is tricky because the other three
fundamental forces aren't really forces
either we don't even call them
fundamental forces
we called them fundamental interactions
and understanding them requires a type
of physics called quantum field theory
and gravity doesn't fit into that very
well
I need to do way more research into qft
before I'm ready to say anything more
thanks for commenting and keep them
coming some of the big questions can
even inspire whole videos also thanks
for liking sharing and subscribing and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy